For the first inequality, I can add 4 to both sides to get negative 3x is
greater than 9. Then we divide by negative 3, the coefficient of x, we get x is
less than negative 3. Remember, we need to reverse the inequality sign here. For
the second inequality, we add 1 to both sides, then we divide by 5 to get x is
less than or equal to negative 4. Notice I don't need to reverse the inequality
sign here because I divided by a positive. We only reverse the inequality sign
when we multiply or divide by a negative. We can graph these solutions on a
number line. x can be any value less than negative 3 here or x can be any value
less than or equal to negative 4 here. But remember, we want x values for either
this inequality or this inequality. Let's see these number lines stacked on top
of each other to decide.